- [Woman] This video is sponsored
by the American Lung Cancer
Screening Initiative.
Lung cancer is the leading cause
of cancer related death in the world.
But lung cancer screening can save lives.
Click the link below to learn more.
Every time you smoke a cigarette
toxic gases pass into your lungs,
then into your bloodstream.
Where they spread to
every organ in your body.
A cigarette is made using the tobacco leaf
which contains nicotine and
a variety of other compounds.
As the tobacco and compounds burn,
they release thousands
of dangerous chemicals,
including over 40 known to cause cancer.
Cigarette smoke contains
the poisonous gases,
carbon monoxide and nitrogen oxide,
as well as trace amounts
of cancer causing radioactive particles.
All forms of tobacco are dangerous,
including cigars, pipes
and smokeless tobacco,
such as chewing tobacco and snuff.
Nicotine is an addictive
chemical in tobacco.
After you inhale tobacco smoke,
nicotine flows through the
bloodstream to your brain,
where it induces a pleasurable feeling.
When you repeatedly expose
your brain to nicotine
it becomes desensitized.
Making you crave more and more
nicotine just to feel normal.
Smoking causes death.
People who smoke typically die
at an earlier age than non-smokers.
In fact, one of every five
deaths in the United States
is linked to cigarette smoking.
If you smoke your risk
of major health problems
increases dramatically
including heart disease,
heart attack, stroke, lung cancer,
and death from chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease.
Smoking causes cardiovascular disease.
When nicotine flows through
your adrenal glands,
it stimulates the release of epinephrine.
A hormone that raises your blood pressure.
In addition, nicotine and carbon monoxide
can damage the lining of the
inner walls in your arteries.
Fatty deposits called plaque
can build up at these injury sites
and become large enough
to narrow the arteries
and severely reduce blood flow
resulting in a condition
called atherosclerosis.
In coronary artery disease,
atherosclerosis narrows the
arteries that supply the heart
which reduces the supply of
oxygen to your heart muscle,
increasing your risk for a heart attack.
Smoking also raises your
risk for blood clots
because it causes platelets in
your blood to clump together.
Smoking increases your risk for
peripheral vascular disease,
in which atherosclerotic plaques
block the large arteries
in your arms and legs.
Smoking can also cause an
abdominal aortic aneurysm.
Which is a swelling or
weakening of your aorta
where it runs through your abdomen.
Smoking damages two main
parts of your lungs.
Your airways also called bronchial tubes
and small air sacs called alveoli.
With each breath,
air travels down your
windpipe called the trachea
and enters your lungs
through your bronchial tubes.
Air then moves into
thousands of tiny alveoli.
Where oxygen from the air
moves into your bloodstream
and the waste product carbon dioxide
moves out of your bloodstream.
Tiny hair-like projections called cilia
line bronchial tubes
and sweep harmful substances
out of your lungs.
Cigarette smoke irritates the lining
of your bronchial tubes,
causing them to swell and make mucus.
Cigarette smoke also slows
the movement of your cilia
causing some of the smoke and
mucus to stay in your lungs.
While you are sleeping
some of the cilia recover
and start pushing more pollutants
and mucus out of your lungs.
When you wake up your body
attempts to expel this material
by coughing repeatedly.
A condition known as smoker's cough.
Over time, chronic bronchitis develops
as your cilia stop working.
Your airways become clogged
with scars and mucus
and breathing becomes difficult.
Your lungs are now more
vulnerable to further disease.
Cigarette smoke also damages your alveoli,
making it harder for
oxygen and carbon dioxide
to exchange with your blood.
Over time so little oxygen
can reach your blood
that you may develop emphysema.
A condition in which you
must gasp for every breath
and wear an oxygen tube under your nose
in order to breathe.
Chronic bronchitis and emphysema
are collectively called
chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease or COPD.
COPD is a gradual loss
of the ability to breathe
for which there is no cure.
Cigarette smoke contains
at least 40 cancer causing
substances called carcinogens,
including cyanide, formaldehyde,
benzene and ammonia.
In your body, healthy cells grow,
make new cells, then die.
Genetic material inside
each cell called DNA
directs this process.
If you smoke, toxic chemicals
can damage the DNA in your healthy cells.
As a result, your damaged cells
create new unhealthy cells.
Which grow out of control
and may spread to other
parts of your body.
The most common cancer in
the world is lung cancer,
with over a million new
cases diagnosed every year.
Harmful chemicals in cigarettes
can cause cancer in
other parts of your body,
such as in the blood and bone marrow,
mouth, larynx, throat, esophagus, stomach,
pancreas, kidney, bladder,
uterus and cervix.
Smoking can cause infertility
in both men and women.
If a woman is pregnant and
smokes during pregnancy,
she exposes her baby to the
cigarette's poisonous chemicals
causing a greater risk
of low birth weight,
miscarriage, preterm delivery, stillbirth,
infant death and sudden
infant death syndrome.
Smoking is also dangerous if
a mother is breastfeeding.
Nicotine passes to the
baby through breast milk
and can cause restlessness,
rapid heartbeat,
vomiting, interrupted sleep or diarrhea.
Other health effects of smoking
include low bone density
and increased risk for
hip fracture among women,
gum disease often leading
to tooth loss and surgery,
immune system dysfunction
and delayed wound healing
and sexual impotence in men.